foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
hello
how are we doing today
hello
welcome welcome welcome
so
first off
how are you hope you had a great day
or if your day is just starting hope
you're having a good one
you're gonna show us how to go 10-0 in
Fight Club listen
uh I'm gold
ranking duels by the way
I don't know what that means I don't
know how the ranking system works at all
uh but I think that's good
I got a level 150 ready to go
can't enter Discord
Oh you mean the normal one I don't know
why that is Kirby I don't know what you
did Buddy
I don't I have no idea what you did man
I just don't see you at all like you
were not banned from the Discord so I
don't know
I don't know what to tell you
Pro Gamer goes undefeated in Elden ring
Fight Club yep
that's me
definitely Bots keep tracks separately
okay I'll talk to booted
we'll see what boot it's got going on
with that because he mentioned something
the other day about it
but we'll see
Bill Clinton is the final boss of course
of course of course
[Music]
okay does do any of you guys know how
fight or not fight club
but how the rank system works is that
explained anywhere
yeah I need some like different music
[Music]
okay
berserk build by the way
I started watching the anime and it's
actually pretty good
[Music]
didn't even know they were ranks yeah
look at this
look at the top
the uh dual United combat or you're kind
of like the chat kind of blocks it but
you can see the duel
the like I don't even know if that's
gold it looks like gold under duel but
it's like a different logo
than the other two
anime removes a lot of stuff yeah that's
okay
whatever
I'm not reading the manga so
isn't that just two two people
you mean a duel yes
Mass Effect legendary edition cool
[Music]
it's a comedy
berserk
now I'm just confused
okay so to get all this out of the way
uh this is our first time doing this
okay so there's gonna be a lot of
scuffness to it
of course
I want to in the future have some sort
of system
where we can keep track of everybody's
record I think that would be awesome
[Music]
now if you guys didn't know this about
me
I used to be known in the rocket League
community
for hosting really big money tournaments
for the the biggest tournament I ever
had on Twitch was for thirteen hundred
dollar 1v1 tournament
and that was pretty cool
now will we ever get to that level on
here I don't know
that'd be cool
maybe someday
but we're just gonna try it out I've
never done PVP in Eldon ring before
uh or in any from software game
today I did today I've played in the day
the game came out I played the the
coliseum's
updated I played then for a few hours
and I had a lot of fun
other than that I have no experience in
PvP at all so I don't know what makes
people mad I don't know like
maybe there are certain things that we
should
not have be an option like you said
Giants flame and PVP one shots I don't
know if that's like a thing people need
to be like yeah
let's just uh
let's not use that or we can make that a
rule
you know what I mean
Adrian
thank you for the eight months sir
I appreciate it thank you very much
welcome back to the tarnish baby
appreciate it
make sure to go to the
Community tab on the channel and then
you can get access to the fight club
Discord
I think I linked a new one today
always bow
my sword thanks it's pretty big
don't you think
anything goes it's not meta so no one
shot okay see I don't know these things
I have no idea
that rocket League bro I'm stuck mine
using your moonline Greatsword to help
me out
no we don't talk about rocket League
anymore even though I just did
yes it's quite a girthy
girthy boy but I feel like I haven't
been doing that bad
in duels I'm just gonna play for a
minute
like sometimes I lose
and sometimes I don't that's all
I'm actually gonna turn this off because
it gets kind of crazy
damn it
all right who we got here
excuse me
I always say hi
every single time
and this guy just does that to me bro
you kidding me
all right come here dog come here dog
yeah
this guy didn't Bow by the way
mm-hmm
that didn't work
what am I what what that works
okay wait watch this
oh
I tried
Buffs are earned not given what does
that mean gotcha
[Music]
what the heck is that
foreign
it doesn't hurt him oh it's the perfumer
move huh that's right that's right
owned oh
I'm almost dead
wait
I knew you'd go for that oh
the Bloodhound step right at the end huh
man
disrespectful
no wave nothing
no honor
that was so close
that was a good fight
I don't like the uh
the no wave man you gotta wave
I didn't get the buff or anything
pure diss kind of hurt my feelings I'm
not gonna lie
this guy will wave 100
hey
hey my man or girl
oh yeah we like you
a whip huh
that didn't hit by the way just so you
know
that didn't hit
ow
that didn't either apparently
dude I had so much range
wait
do I just have a worse connection than
this person
okay
I still got hit feels bad man
whoa
okay I'm sorry I feel like that was kind
of stupid
was that just a connection diff
well I won a bunch of matches earlier
today and now I've lost two in a row
I got owned
but at least they were honorable
there's like a half second lag between
hits or something for PVP don't remember
the exact stats but it's funny
yeah that's like probably my least
favorite thing about PVP
is that because I see you know I
literally see blood
I'm up
and nothing
just just no hit
that's probably my least favorite thing
I think everything else is awesome like
I love seeing the the variety of
different builds between people it's
really fun to see
especially like I'm level 150 I don't
know if that's different just based on
level it probably does because you
probably have more things if you're uh
higher level and less things if you're a
lower level but
it's cool it's fun the summon fights are
mental we should we should do one of
those
we should
um so there is a password system
that I want to put in the fight club
Discord
I just really I don't know how it works
does it does anybody know
like you also put in the password and
then we fight against each other
when we queue up with the password is
that it
oh we're always learning baby always
yeah I guess we can try I mean does does
anyone like know
again I've never been a PVP
hi
what's your name
Melvin thick
all right Melvin
let's go buddy
that didn't hit by the way even though I
see blood
all right 222 we'll take it ow I think
well this guy's like high rank you see
that
what up metal
okay we get a little scuffy hits in
I hate this spell
nice
it's a cool combo he's got there
do I have to be a certain
yeah
ah don't bait me in you [ __ ] Melvin
thick
he's keeping his distance
I'm going for it no I had him
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
no
we almost traded
oh man now I'm bad
what a metal
I almost got a man [ __ ]
I was doing so good earlier today and
now I'm just not good
man
I'm going again
all these fights have been good
I just don't win
this build's really fun though
I like having the
the you got to get good with the timing
on the crossbow look at this guy man
no wave uh you don't need a wave
I like this guy wait his name is guts
real
the two berserk builds going at it huh
this guy scares the [ __ ] out of me
holy [ __ ]
I think I could one shot this guy
this guy's better than me I feel it in
my bones
he's lagging as well
nice
did not one shot him
[Music]
is that a fist
I refuse to believe that didn't hit
this guy's better than me at this game
oh my God
this
god dude I'm so bad
oh that's like
yeah yeah
max amount of players fights team free
for all yeah I've tried all I've tried
that it's pretty fun I've just been
doing duels recently I think they're
intense
I just want to win one before we
actually start I just want to win one
time
one fight
the PVP mechanics are really weird
bite me
you need to get a PC metal
now
it's probably for pairing and fast
attacks yeah this guy looks like are you
[ __ ] kidding me poor Lou oh
the disrespect on this man
putting it on my name [ __ ]
it didn't hit I'm
I feel like I'm losing just on
connection I don't know why
foreign
how is that not hitting what the [ __ ]
look he's gliding around
he's trying to kill me now
that did not seem right I'm sorry
you got it PVP is different with the
balance of weapons
that guy was a dick too he didn't even
say hi
gotta say hi bro
I guess I'm just bad yeah I don't know
but I feel like I hit him a couple times
there
you need to get a PC metal that's what I
said
it is not cross-platform unfortunately
that'd be neat though
we gonna get a high out of somebody
I like your sword
hey all right you're the man you're the
man bro
okay
his name is just strangers
that's kind of cool
kind of a little bait there
I just want to win one fight
what
and what's going on
dude there's like [ __ ] blood man I I
what the heck
I
there cheats
there's a hit
foreign
delayed
eat a lot of Save Editor uses in
Coliseum according to my mate on
PlayStation
the blood particles is actually kind of
a from software thing that needs to be
patched if you perfect time a Dodge it
does that
huh
well it's really frustrating
I'm gonna go here
it's very frustrating to see blood and
you just don't do any damage
it's lying to me
the stream worsens your connection I'm
not streaming on the same PC that I'm
playing on so that's not possible
glome eye Queen
all right I guess we're just buffing
over here all right
no they bowed they bowed they bowed hold
up yeah yeah yeah yeah
good
okay
I don't know what you got on that thing
but it's scaring me
that was good that was good by me
for sure that was good too
this does not look like a glow my queen
oh okay
okay
that's a big hit
[ __ ] man
that is so frustrating
foreign
give it to me straight am I just bad
give it to me straight
if I'm bad I'm bad but you gotta tell me
if they could manage cross-platform that
would be huge yeah it actually would
it actually would
I want to win one time man
upload Network stream and PVP I don't
know what that means
probably
listen this is my first time PVP
in any from software game okay
give me some slack please
and stop being mean
y'all are being kind of mean
some of you anyway
Carter's being mean
for the double hit
nice
it seems like if I just run straight
back I always get hit
this guy's a bike
[Music]
okay
I'm feeling it
I'm getting some cheeky hits in
I did it let's go
let's go
I won
I did it
I won
oh wait should I abound [ __ ]
damn let's go some people are insane in
PvP do you just get used to the lag
I actually think the gut weapon is
pretty good
I think you just get used to the build
that you have right
like yeah there's always gonna be like
you know Moon Veil when the game first
came out right
at least from what I heard everyone
bitched and moaned about it with PVP
I did get over excited and forgot my
manners that's my bad
um but I feel like you just get used to
your build and you
that it I don't know I could be wrong I
don't know
okay
how are we gonna do this guys
how do you want to do this
for the for the Fight Club
we could just duel one another
PVP is not worth saving yes it is having
a good multiplayer for any game makes
the game better why not like you know
why not
right
you just get mad at it
today's Giants flames and lightning
strike are the triggers
referral okay how many members are on PC
right now this is a members only fight
club by the way
just to help moderate this entire thing
because we could get some pretty bad
people
you're not a member fraud
okay we got a few
we got a few I'm gonna try something so
I'm gonna go in the
I'm gonna go in the fight club Discord
which I believe Angel and goslinger and
you're in those right
I'm gonna type the password
don't say it in the YouTube chat
obviously
okay and then I'm gonna hide
yep yep
so I'm putting it in there it's there
this is how I used to do this for Rocket
League by the way so I'm gonna hide
screen
I'm still here though calm down calm
down
if I had a PC I would damn bro this
really needs to be cross-platform
it really does
but here's the other cool part if you
find somebody who is also a member
in the fight club Discord who is on the
same platform as you you could get in
contact with them and say like hey you
wanna you wanna fight
you know what I mean that could be fun
good way to make friends as well
okay hold on let me let me figure this
out
hmm so I'm just gonna put it in
and I'm gonna start inner combat
let's see if that works
can you send Discord link it is linked
uh so if you go to the community tab on
our page broadly you'll be able to see
it
just go to the community tab
and you'll get a link
it'll be a members only thing
I think PC modding makes cross-plat a
little bit of a no-go
um other games are modded in their
cross-platform so that's that's a
possibility I think they definitely can
you can't do any of the modding when
you're online in this game so I don't
think that would that would change
anything
I can't see it due to my device what
device are you on
because you will definitely be able to
see it
but I can't put the Discord Link in the
chat that would kind of ruin the point
hey we got one
or at least somebody
okay who we got
who's this
who's crystal
hi hey
Samsung A3 tablet why is that stopping
you
that's you Angel all right let's go
no no no no don't don't don't be scared
no no no no no
father all right you ready
thank you Finn welcome buddy
thanks for the membership man I
appreciate it
angel you are lagging all over the
[ __ ] world right now bro
nice
[Music]
is it bad that I have a crossbow like
does that annoy people or is that okay
oh my God I got [ __ ] poison
I gotta kill you I gotta kill you now
No Angel
don't do me like this
bro I'm worse than my chat
holy crap
I think I'm just really bad
good fight Angel Good Fight
your build is
awesome actually
your build's pretty cool my guy
I'm gonna keep doing that password
though
crossbows are fine for me crossbow is
fine
take it ratio there's no ratio to have
here I know I'm not good at the PVP but
I think it's fun
I could [ __ ] annihilate any main boss
in the game though just saying
oh it's Cobalt I know Cobalt yo yo
hi
password Works cool
also does my buffing do anything
no we're not telling you the password
that would kind of ruin the point of
being a member all right let's go
why are you so brave
no
the reduvia
all right
okay watch this watch this
oh
[Music]
I told you to watch
probably do this right
[Music]
okay wait I know what to do somebody
told me in chat
poke
oh my God I almost died good fight good
fight
in honorable fight Cobalt honorable
I did it though
send me an invite please dude
Ben thank you again for becoming a
tarnish I appreciate it
um also go to the community tab it you
are not limited by your device I promise
that was a great fight though he like if
he bled me there I was dead
oh that was you gasly
there is somebody who is a member in our
community named Cobalt by the way
a good fight good fight that was fun all
right let's go again I'm just gonna keep
doing the password
um Let me let me change it up a bit
let's do
combat ordeal
um we'll do any number of combatants
and we just like fight against each
other
that I I changed the settings
I watch your streams enough I might as
well that's good Finn
I appreciate it man
if anybody would like to join us and
join the fight club Discord there is a
link
the first link in the description
to become a member it's three bucks
if you want to go higher than that you
can I'd appreciate it but it's just like
the best way for us to moderate
everything you know what I mean
yeah I have tried one with Spirit ashes
it's actually kind of fun
that's a different Discord Lord Farquaad
Rock quad
that's our main Discord
yeah I did any Coliseum
I think we found one
yeah yeah yeah yeah
Spirit ashes alone go insane
I think I have every item in the game
with this character so it's possible
doing some randoms got one-shotted I'm
sorry sir that must hurt you probably
need armor
or to
up your vigor
it's very chaotic yeah that's kind of
the point
the first time I went to the Khalid
Coliseum I was like holy [ __ ] what's
going on
it was actually kind of fun
I really am though how is that possible
you just click on my channel and then go
to community tab bro
it's not hard you're if you're watching
a stream
then you can definitely hit the
community tab
definitely
how old is that device
must be old as balls but if you're
watching the stream then you gotta be
good
see why does it say remaining combatants
when I set it to any couldn't it just
like after a little bit it should just
go with what we got
what's up snatches
uh some are trying to turn this into
Pokemon letting the ashes duke it out
that's kind of cool
I like that
are you gonna post more on agency Jakey
yeah I plan to I just don't know what to
put on there
there's like nothing to do on there
right now
the Callisto protocol was like kind of
the last game we were looking for
okay I don't think this worked hold on
I'm canceling it
password any number of so any number of
compatants did not work
it just automatically goes to six
hmm
should I just do like four
what's this drive four and see if we can
get it any location combat or deal four
combatants and just do the password
okay
the same password
I'm down for letting this be Pokemon
maybe some fights we do that some we
don't you know
um
is it United no it's just like it would
be a free-for-all I believe
we just all duke it out
I had a ruins great sword build that I
was doing on the day that this came out
and it was actually really fun
[Music]
Pride I'm I don't appreciate what you're
doing okay buddy like begging for it and
then trying to guess it
calm down hi tan man
yeah I just don't think we have enough
people right now
hmm
okay I'm gonna change it again
we'll go back to what we were doing
because I don't think it's gonna work
like this
but I think if like let's say four of us
are queuing
well it'll just be like random right
like who goes against who
I think gifted memberships are also a
thing like if you get lucky you might
get gifted a membership if somebody is
so generous
it's it's literally so we did this with
rocket league and it was the best way to
to do it we used to do open tournaments
and that was just the worst thing ever
in terms of moderation
Oh Valencia hello
all right see who is this yeah I went
back to duel
the other thing just wasn't working
oh oh okay okay oh
okay oh [ __ ]
I just got [ __ ] up so I forgot what it
did
foreign
I literally forgot what the moon does
not a two-shotter baby let's go
good fight
posted proof in the Discord okay
I don't need proof
your text is all weird too okay okay I
got you hold on
I got you that is crazy
but okay uh
hi okay
yeah your your device just must be
[ __ ] awful
who who was that that was youfin good
fight sir good fight
and boom
all right
there you go rodley
boom
almost posted it in the normal Discord
that would have been bad
2018 that's not that old that's very
surprising
I guess YouTube is just dumb what's your
pink Peak rank in Rocky League
oh I was a top hundred player in every
playlist at least the main competitive
playlist wants twos and threes
they queue it up again
I was top hundred
supersonic Legend
it makes sense making it members though
could try random rotating password for
chat if need
makes sense if members
though could try a random password we
could
this might be a more mature Community
than the rocket League community
we just had much more success moderating
everything
in the uh
when it was like subscribers only when
we did it on Twitch
I had to delete my game
what'd you delete it for what game were
you playing
yeah I I hope they do cross-platform
they or she please I got you
no problema
yeah that was a great fight
we go again
all right
that was Finn
white and Finn again
I won't I won't buff this time
let's get it
whoa what is that
I don't think I've ever seen that spell
before
all right this is how I started last
time right guys
it's going good
what Hound's step is well huh
I feel like that was just out of range
unfortunately
nice I can kind of power through a lot
of hits
great fight Finn
close one yet again
nothing it just wouldn't load for some
reason
yeah I have a lot of poise
makes sense with the the heavy strength
build you know
I always have Elden ring bloodborne or
sakuro installed are you on PlayStation
what's the code you have to be a member
to get the code
Vincent
all right Gastly
this looks like a nope it's the same
build just without the mask
let's get it
okay okay buff it up buff it up I'll
buff two I'll buff two
off a little bit all right
man I really wish this was
cross-platform what do you what are the
percentages of Elden ring players
on each device
figuring out the timing with the
crossbow is really fun
all right power stance
oh
what is that
okay I know that move
oh that hurt my soul
okay I was just out of range I think
cut it out
no she just went for it
good fight good fight good fight the
bleed is nuts
use Rod Arrows with that crossbow
that's probably a good idea
foreign
not quite used to duels
that's a the wrong Discord
we have two discords one for members
and one just a main Discord
you have to be a member to get the code
I think we have enough for four okay
we'll do one more
and I'll try fours again
[Music]
but I did I did notice earlier today
when I was just testing this build
that
I had like
I I got a little bit addicted to it
you know what I mean
like I I would lose or win win or lose
and I would just queue up again I'd just
go again
you know just go again go again go again
go again and I found myself doing it for
like a couple hours I'm like dang this
is actually pretty fun once you get used
to it and kind of accept that it's kind
of like not the best you know
soul
uh it was really fun I had a good time
I'm buffing
you get one hey from me
you are very confident
maybe I should be more confident
[Music]
good timing on that one
uh yes you rotted me before
okay I'm dead it's over
man that gets me fast huh
oh let's go let's go holy moly okay I
got too excited
that was a good fight holy crap I should
have died
that was kinda awesome
who was that I forget
that was a great fight I think that was
you Angel right
holy
yeah if I land that heavy attack it is
over
okay
I'm gonna cue fours now
uh see if we can get it get it working
combat ordeal for combatants with the
same thing on any location
you got it rod
uh I looked it up 63 000 players on
right now
41 percenter on Playstation really
dang
good fight Angel Good Fight
41 huh
it's crazy
we need two more
I'm on a 2018 device
oh you're fun
jump me with two great swords while I
was bowing
dang Kirby
got another one in the Discord
wait
Shake got the anime move at the end yup
yup yup yup yup that's me
anime
need one more
PC's too high maintenance
for for Eldon ring like to run like you
need a good computer I can see that
Bloodhound step opinion
it's fine is it not is it not
I think it's fine I haven't played
enough to think otherwise
[Music]
oh now we need two more
was that how it was working though like
if we all just queued the same password
for duals we just randomly get against
each other
yeah I think it's fine
I thought it would give moonvale Vibes
considering I think it's broken you
think it's still broken
it just seems like a a cool looking
Dodge
right
like I don't think it really puts you
out of range depending on what you have
oh need one more again
Bloodhound step is okay after Nerf
especially players who used it
tactically and not just an escape method
I did fight someone earlier who didn't
wave at me
and [ __ ] uh
bammed Bloodhound step with rivers of
blood wearing malacat's armor and I'm
like this player has not played Elden
ring since March
laughs
and I annihilated that person
I thought that was pretty funny
I think we still need one more we might
go back to duels until we get like one
that's like yo I'm here let's go
yeah do we have to all have the same uh
thingy
like combat ordeal combatant selection
any location
you think it would just throw you in
with whatever the password is you know
I don't think it's broken anymore
regarding moonvale I fought one Moon
Veil person and all I thought to myself
was this is extremely easy to dodge
like I didn't have trouble at all
it's better to use rolled and blow down
stuff because they're the same thing but
it costs you a ash of War
okay we are going
to go back to duels and we'll just wait
till we get more that's all
this is our first night trying to do
this by the way
so hopefully as we do this more often
it will uh
it'll just be easier to find matches
with more people you know what I mean
it cancels the match making a bit after
if it takes too long that makes sense
yeah Bloodhound step just kind of looks
cooler
you're down gotta be a member if you
want to play and be on PC I really wish
it was
uh cross platform
I'm actually having a great time Crimson
I think I think the PVP is overall very
fun
and I'm glad I tried it
because before I was just like way too
scared to even try it
we meet again
we meet again
okay okay okay that's fair that's fair
I'm fine with it
I'm fine with it
might give you one of oh
gotcha
poke
get off my back
I didn't have the Poise I wanted there
nice we got the range we got the range
let's go let's go
good timing
random throw
what is this I don't like it
she's
oh I caught you slacking
great fight
I think I caught you trying to go back
the other way
good fight
great fight GG
caught you slacking
God I love dueling
I just showed the password didn't I
dang it I forgot
well guess what I'm gonna change it
laughs
oh that's gonna happen a lot but it's
nice that I can just change it
okay different different look to you
here
oh you're snapping at me
you snapping okay
okay
I lose I lose to you pretty much every
time don't I
okay ready ready
yup didn't expect me to just run huh
random aggression
good range yay oh
okay watch watch
let's go sorry wrong emote I got you
I think you were typing that and I
killed you
I'm sorry
good fight good fight good fight
I figured it was just the wrong one I
was just talking [ __ ] because it's fun
all right now I gotta change the
password because [ __ ]
uh fried frog is gonna have an aneurysm
all right I'm changing it and put in the
Discord
this is a weird one
nothing like the one we had before
new password
you don't know if I'm telling the truth
or not
I just showed it again I'm an idiot
changing it
I'm literally just gonna edit that one
I'm bad uh let me think let me think
all right
off the screen
I can't believe I did that
all right there's a new password I got
it updated
you have an editor for your videos no I
do everything myself
okay I fixed it we're good
I'm gonna have to hide again though
because I didn't enter
okay
healing
queuing
85 watching 19 likes come on guys
nobody's liking the stream come on guys
like the damn stream
I'd appreciate it thank you
it's the new new
pew
the new new pew pew
all right
disliked I hate you
all right
we beat again
everyone's forgets to like
all right there's a lot of moves on that
one huh
you're a wizard
okay this one I won with a final heavy
attack last time
that move scares me
come on
oh
imagine imagine
got the range got the range
all right
oh
you trying to bait there kinda
there we go
another good fight
GG
what does a like actually do in terms of
YouTube growth uh it tells the algorithm
that people like the video
you know
you know
do you mean again
it makes the owl like the YouTube Gods
go oh people like this
we should promote it to more people
I get an insane amount of likes compared
to the uh views I get
we meet again I'm gonna say that every
time we meet again
I like the uh pretty much just the
Millicent fit cool
oh I wasn't loaded
okay we're going for the hit
no I thought it was far enough back
okay we got one
wait isn't that astal's sword
nice I got the drag
[Music]
whack
maybe I'm lagging
I don't know all right we're gonna win
this chat right here
man the movement of that sword is very
strange nice
don't you dare
what
wait I didn't lose health
that was big
nice
don't you dare
yeet
oh my gosh
come on
great fight holy crap that was actually
really close
great fight
good stuff
yeah arrows respawn after PVP
great fight that was actually sick
it's Wrecking me vids with three views
the algorithm yeah I've been getting the
same I don't know what's going on with
YouTube lately I think it's being kind
of weird
yeah it's mantis blade
right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
how do I participate in set event well
Mr Trump you gotta become a member and
then you go to the community Tab and you
will get a Discord link to the fight
club Discord and then you'll see the
password in there
we meet again
is it just proper to email anything
I didn't mean to do that I thought I had
to load I'm sorry
usually I have to load
at first
hit me
you're crazy
I can delay that heavy swing too by the
way it's kind of cool
if I can get used to that
I hate this dodged
man you're you're hard you're hard
no
no
don't do me like this
I'm gonna have to one shot
you don't have Mana
ah
damn it now you have Mana
[Music]
fight good fight
couldn't roll man
uh watching other peeps it could be a
good idea to do a separate live Channel
as it does affect smaller channels more
going live than bigger ones like
fighting cowboy
I have thought about that what do you
guys think of doing that
what do you think of that
because I could just make AGT Jakey the
live stream channel
and just put lore videos on this one
also that was a great fight
dude this is [ __ ] fun I I'll say it
I am very surprised
that it took me this long to try PVP in
these games it's fun
dude Google pay is the worst
no idea how it works for the algorithm I
think our views on the streams are fine
is this stream on here but it could help
I don't I just don't know
hey
I am getting hooked I am literally
getting hooked
I'm level 150 I don't know what
everybody else is
oh
be the blood
all right good trade
[ __ ]
millennia
[ __ ]
dang you annihilated me
good fight
I I just got
cooked
absolutely cooked dude
I think the reason YouTube is
recommending five two views is YouTube
could be giving small creators a chance
to grow so they can benefit
uh I mean do you actually watch those
Valencia is 159 okay it's around the
same another good fight
all the fights have been good since we
started dueling
it's fun
150 is the agreed PVP level that's what
I heard
so I just went with 150
twitch no I hate twitch
no I only know English
I don't know
could do that and then people who are
members here
have access
are the low view videos being
recommended relevant what we've watched
before
I mean you think you'd think I'd know
how the algorithm works
I don't think anybody does
I think even if you have like a million
subscribers I don't even think they know
yeah it's a guts build it's actually
really fun
we meet again
all right
let's go
I need to beat you
oh can you not you don't have to do the
third attack if you don't want that's
kind of cool
good sequence
oh that staggers I thought I could go
through that maybe
got through that one
no I almost caught he's slipping
nice
having that is an option
just the throwing dagger is huge
great fight
I feel like I'm getting better as we go
but sometimes I have a bad fight
good stuff good stuff
the algorithm the algorithm is a mystery
to itself well I've had the Assumption
recently that I don't think an algorithm
exists
you know
I don't even think it's a thing
having an algorithm
oh you're changing up the weapon I see
okay
you got two of them oh God I'm dead
aren't I
I'm dead it's over
I am not gonna live through this
that [ __ ] scares the piss out of me
foreign
I just went for it let's go baby
great fight I almost never go for two
hits
I just can't I always hit once and back
off that time I went for two and it
worked
great fight
the one pump trump welcome baby thanks
for becoming an Elden Lord
So It Begins welcome sir
go to the community tab you'll see a
members only post you'll see the Discord
link there and then I think you got to
scroll up a little bit but it should be
uh
The password should be there
I should like make a password tab
I'm really good now I feel like I'm
getting better but I shouldn't gas
myself up too much
you know what I mean
you know what I'm saying
I'm having a good time hopefully this is
actually fun to do
for everybody else I'm having fun
hopefully it's fun to watch too
I I've been I've been watching some
twitch streams
for PVP I've noticed that YouTube
streams don't really stream it besides
fighting cowboy
I'll try to I'll try different weapon so
I'm just having fun with this one right
now
I want to have the bow I don't have any
emotes on this guy
oh
I struggle against you good start though
nice
okay wait no
I almost got you there there it is
that didn't hit
pain
all the pain in my heart
okay wait I'm gonna do something that
I'm bad at
poke
backing up is also just not the move huh
oh
poke
no great fight I kind of went trash mode
there
I went trash Mo trash mode bro
you have two rivers of Bloods if you
have two rivers of Bloods
work on your spacing a little more in
valuable trades yeah I think my spacing
is bad I am learning that if I go
straight back
I pretty much always get hit if they do
an attack so I need to like go to a side
or roll in
and that helps a lot
gg gg good stuff good stuff
popping in the ring let's go Trump
you're on PC right
hopefully
can't wait to try with summons I think
now that we got Trump we can try and do
the four player thing
I can turn on summons if you want
foreign hey
hey
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
buff
I don't normally do this but here we are
I have quite literally never seen that
attack before that was lit
so I'm dead huh
I think that was a good trade
or wouldn't let me roll
I'm I'm kind of bad at going straight
back aren't I
nice
close
don't do that I don't know what you're
doing
that almost worked
um
oh get my help look at my [ __ ] help
what a fight
let's go I went for the Poke and I think
I just out damaged
you fight good fight good stuff
holy that was close
you're kind of bad period shut the [ __ ]
up metal
I tried to switch it up bro that was so
close
the last minute poke boy there
are you excited for the new armored Core
yeah
did that trailer for armored Core not
just pump you guys up because that
trailer was [ __ ] awesome
need a bigger health bar
yeah okay let me try the uh four person
so it's gonna be
combat ordeal for combatants let's do no
Spirit actions same password any
location
so we're trying four now
how much you how mad would you be if I
slapped your booty with my butter knife
switch it up with a real knife
and I'm in
I'm just doing all coliseums
Mr Trump
uh I was playing Team fights at level 93
and I felt like I could barely deal
damage to some opponents and got one
shot at many times I think everyone's
like level 150
or is using their their main character
you know
yep and then you got to put in the
password
I was always in a knife play metal you
just didn't give me a chance
bada bing bada boom Oh we did it let's
go all right all right I'm excited for
this I don't know what to expect
you just didn't give me a chance I'm
just saying I love knife play look at
this knife
I didn't reach hi everyone
hey all right so how do we do this
do we do we really just do free-for-all
or should we like choose one another
I'm going in
I'm scared
ah
get away from me
nice
I'm coming for you
no
all the pain in my heart
owie
I want to be covered in blood you said
that's gross it is gross I didn't say no
laughs
big hits there yay let's go
that was a good play and you know it
we keep going baby
all right here we go here we go
yeah I see you coming for me
boom
breakthrough baby my pulleys is
unmatched
it does sound fun booted hello hello
I'm kind of getting in the middle of
things I ain't gonna mess with this
fight they've been going at it a while
um I forgot I started a new game on my
main half discover locations rip that is
a Rippy dippy sir are you not here
you cut this out Bang Bang
I see you I see you
yeah I feel like I only uh they have
armor kinda
all right let's go
I'm feeling you
God damn
oh we traded I got annihilated by the
moon
I'm wearing the uh
Knight's Cavalry armor with just like a
black hood
sweep
it's kind of cool that I can change who
I'm focused on Mid heavy attack like I
can just do that
oh okay
dang bro
holy crap
yeah yeah yeah
totally didn't mean to beat my crossbow
oh my gosh
I almost tried to tank your hits and it
didn't work
the swing would you heal
Bang
chicken and shrimp
we traded baby I think
I we did trade that was kind of lit
oh wait I can use a flask in this that's
right we were dueling and you can't use
a flask
okay Cobalt oh my God
oh my God
ma'am
yup yup yup yup yup yup
boom
look at that I I switched sides
great fight everybody dude that's fun I
love that holy [ __ ]
who won
I did
I got the dub okay
I had Nine Kills
that's not bad
am I getting better
as we go
all right what do you guys want to do
free for all again or
duels again
that was really fun
also how many do we have
winner gets feet picks
let's go that's me
oh yeah let's try summons
Peru hold on
Peru dude what should I use
I'm gonna use a mad pumpkin head
that sounds fun okay I'm cueing it again
and I'm turning on Spirit ashes
but yeah that was actually super fun
I can see inside Jakey the sickness is
rising
uh oh
use the unkillable great Shield soldiers
dude if I use my ruins great sword build
those things get absolutely Fried by the
ash war on that weapon
or
yeah yeah
same thing as before just Spirit ashes
turned on
yep we got it let's go baby
let's go baby
should we just do the Pokemon battle
it does it went through the shields for
me Henry
mad pumpkin head I Choose You
I
okay
uh all right come on
wait
they don't fight each other
get out of here [ __ ]
you're dead
wait my boy's dead too
no man
so they don't attack each other they
just attack us
that's pain
all the pain in my heart
wait a Chris stallion is actually really
smart
however I'm
I'm killing you
how strong is this [ __ ]
it also
disappeared
that scared me I want you to know that
that scared me
foreign
okay I think the spirit summons are
not the best
how do people do Pokemon if they like
don't attack you
cha cha cha
gotcha-cha
cut it out that hurt
you're about to get shot holy [ __ ] was
that a storm Hawk
all right I'm bringing him back out
I'm gonna die in the process but he's
here
get him buddy
go knock him with your face
[Music]
oh I don't have SP pain
pumpkin head I need you
let's go
we got the poke
[Music]
the swing the swing
it hurt
Bang Bang
Bang
[Music]
oh I went for the big hit
you got the Wii pot
I don't think pot boy is very good what
do you guys think
he's not the best
uh-oh
that's gonna be bad for us I already
feel it
I hate that attack dude
Melania
[Music]
this really is just pure chaos
it's kind of great
let's go pothead
ah that didn't work
wait I'm dead
first one
no bruh
God damn it
I'm back
and I'm coming for you
no
Bang Bang
I'm getting frisbied right now
nice good kill
no
great fight everybody I definitely
didn't win that one
[Laughter]
oh yeah he's not pot boy he's pumpkin
head however he he doesn't have a pot on
his head I misspoke
I misspoke
all right what do we think do we want to
keep Spirit summons or get them out
do whatever you guys want
and then keep doing fours or
or duels again
[Music]
get them out
metal says get them out
she's not even playing
I can get him out of here
Team Battle oh yeah let's do that let's
do that let's do that we're gonna do
okay
we're gonna do four combatants United
combat no Spirit at let's just try no
Spirit ashes for this one
uh desire team no preference
same password all players any location
I think I have every Ash fully upgraded
on this character
so we could destroy everything
are they fighting and typing they're
just good like that like they're just
they're just quick with it you know
I have faced zero Bill Clinton's
looks like nobody was uh
you know
one to change
their name I guess
[Music]
you need one more
huamo
this is so surprisingly fun
did you see someone modded Bill Clinton
into the game already
one more
oh why there we go we got it baby
we got it
all right whose team am I on
let's go Valencia
we got this I ain't worried about it I'm
gonna RP walk right on over
I'll give him a little wave here hey and
then guess what
State at the plate I don't know okay get
out of here with that
get out of here with that
cha cha
how's my teammate doing
not good I gotta go in
come here baby
I'm just waiting I know what to do I
know what to do
boom
that's right
mm-hmm
I'd switched it up
hey
hey
little Pokey big swing
I am very surprised I didn't hit you out
of the air
nice big swinger yep yep yep oh let's go
Valencia
what a [ __ ] shot damn the timing
Bang Bang
I'm almost dead unfortunately
yeah
okay wait no hey
cut it out
I misimed it
yes I'm almost dead
yeah okay
dude I'm getting so into it that I'm
making grunting noises with my character
[Music]
that'd be kind of fun metal
I'm coming Valencia
hopefully that helped
it didn't
I'm gonna get you whoop no poke
okay wait wait
little faint poke let's go
I legit feel myself getting better
[Music]
I'm going for the heavy
not worth
hey if
if you got a PC metal
that sounds good
I can also hold the bolts
and get the right timing if I want I
just realized that look I'm holding
holding
you know it didn't work but you know I
was trying to
poke
blah blah blah
no bops
let's go Valencia no I couldn't get away
we like the noises
PCS are expensive
uh depends on your PC to be honest
oh that attack is scary
oh
let's go metal that's good to hear wait
I thought that was my teammate who lived
I'm gonna give you a little Pokey yep
no my Dodge didn't work but we got
through it baby let's go
oh valence he's got that in the back oh
my God oh my God
I believed in my poke going for the
double
roll in
deal for no reason
bang bang nope wasn't loaded pain
poke poke not a poke poke big heavy
no I thought I could oh no
I thought my insane Poise would just go
all the way through that
that's right big heavy
foreign
yeah I'm seeing a lot of curved swords
we're getting kind of effed right now
no did we did we lose
we did
well Valencia won
so that means
I
won
let's go good [ __ ]
GG that was fun
holy [ __ ] this is fun
imagine if we could get like 12 people
in there bro can you know can you that'd
be so insane
it's not possible as well but it would
be so [ __ ] fun I'm just gonna do that
again
same thing
they had the most kills
why to say Valencia then
you pay is a mess I'm sorry man
he paid doobie a mess
you know what YouTube needs
you guys even do you guys know what
twitch Prime is
YouTube needs this an equivalent to that
like if you have premium you can get a
free membership to somebody
Where's My Water oh it's right here
it's right here
yo is that Cole what up bro
Dr sunshine
oh I'll let it read I'll let it read
thank you for the five
I appreciate it
together
has anyone ever figured out why the
doors in Lionel are waxed were people
locking themselves enduring the siege
for safety
we do not know for sure
at all
what makes the most sense is that
I don't know why people would wax
themselves in for safety I think people
were being put in there and they were
being waxed inside
or nobody's in there
we just don't know there's no way to say
for sure
all right who do I got oh okay rematch
let's go
hey
what kind of hay is that
my guy goes hey that was a hey
I'm coming for you oh new weapons okay
yep new weapons new weapons
going for it I just went for the big
bonkers
I went for the big bonkey Boy Hits
[Music]
finish her off
finish her
cha cha cha
poke
poke
swing
jump
big no I can't
quit that cut it out
stop that
poke
big swing [ __ ]
forget you have a heavy weapon as well
[Music]
Bang Bang
no pain
going for the swings let's go
[Music]
damn Valencia
where the [ __ ]
a character was aimed in the ground
oh I'm crouched
[Music]
oh my God
I'm just throwing this big ass sword
around and hitting
there's no
there's no like strategy to what I'm
doing at all
I'm just throwing this thing around and
it's hitting
let's go baby
[Music]
watch this watch this chat
do you fear me
you should
flag
yeah
I got magic
[ __ ] Harry Potter up in this [ __ ] I
ain't dying today
I died
metal you're being mean to me
I want you to know that
I got you
Bang Bang
poke time
I don't know what this is I don't know
what it does but we're here
RP walking around bro
oh a thousand yay
I didn't hit
wait
no
I had to [ __ ] load again
don't yell at me
[Music]
okay that was us
wait
did you see that [ __ ]
that scared me
is your display named guts no it's Jake
big sword
Miss
big sword hit
I must rest
after my victory
good fight good fight also doctor thank
you again for the five I don't feel like
I said that enough GG fellas that was
fun
dude I went on a murder spree
rest sweet prince this is so much fun
this is actually fun
[Laughter]
I think I'm gonna switch to the ruins
great sword
oh I can't wield it on this character
hmm
we could go full Rick mode chat
foreign
okay we're going again I'm just doing
the same thing
this is why hander
I just found someone saying it was a
plague wax for infected houses I thought
wax because Intruders can't break
enduring Siege but inside can get out
hmm that's interesting is there any
evidence that that there was like an
infection throughout Landell
we don't really see the people that's
true we just see guards and stuff
even if there are we don't know if there
are people or not like actual residents
but thank you for another five doctor I
appreciate it thank you
wax to keep the ash out
the ash I mean it's not always ashy
though
according to tarnish it's a previous
tree burning
dung eater
were they keeping dung eater out he's
locked away Underground
so like do they even need to stay waxed
in
make the sword hardened nah we're gonna
go with this
and what else do I got
I have every weapon I think
I was having fun with this I'm gonna
keep doing it
in my crossbow
crossbow fun I don't really buff so
that's fine
there's Ash before you get the flame of
ruin
you hardened my sword nice
to keep those who live in death inside
the houses
wouldn't that just be tarnished
I I mean technically we're not dead
we just die and come back
so that's different
who's missing who wants to join now we
got two to I think I have to re-cue
hold up I'm gonna re-cue again
canceling
and going again
the skeletons
are there any skeletons in Landell
I don't think so
okay metal
[Laughter]
what the what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] boy
I'm not ashy I use lotion
they used wax
why does America hate malacath I don't
think America hates malacath
I think she used him
I'm seeing theories about it being
corpse wax but others saying it's Amber
wax from the tree
some Reddit discussions claiming a
plague from The Siege because food
rations ran low
where is the evidence for that though
like where does it say that there was
food rations were low in lay and Dell or
some type of plague
why did she use him to
I don't know keep dust and death
because malekith is America's shadow
just like blyde is to Ronnie
so
she told him to
keep destined death
to guard it and malacath thinks America
hates him because he failed somebody
stole a fragment of the Rune of death
Ron malacath and that's why he says to
us I'm no I will never let anyone take
dust and death away from me again you
know what I mean
oh I'm Gonna Keep slaying ghastly I'm
out here bombing we need one more though
we might have to go back to duels until
we get more
oh ghastly had to leave that's why okay
well thank you ghastly thank you for
playing that was fun
the lore in this game is completing
it's complaining I will keep slain thank
you again ghastly for playing I'm gonna
switch back to duels though
we're switching
we gotta get more members to to join up
duel
prohibited any location same password
oh it's complicated yeah it's extremely
complicated that's why it's fun to talk
about though
I'm seeing evidence it seems most of
this is people trying to make rational
connections where they can't find it in
the game I think there's no point in
doing that
I don't think there's like unless it's
specifically is stated or there is solid
evidence to support saying like well
maybe food rations were low
um then I just don't say that you know
because I just don't know you can bring
it up as a possibility but we can't say
for sure that they put people in there
because of a plague that we don't know
about because food rations were low you
know what I mean
I appreciate that doctor I'm glad you
like the videos
I got finished writing the next video
that should be out in the next couple of
days but I gotta edit it down and get
all the footage for it
it's on the chapel of anticipation which
I think has been greatly under talked
about
like I haven't really seen much of
anything talked about it it's actually
quite interesting
hey metal sent me a picture of her foot
guys let's go
metal how's the puppy
is someone gonna join me
hey I'll go I'll go slay random people
yeah maybe this maybe I gotta go again
hold on
let me go again also do you guys like
the screen The Fight Club screen I think
it's lit
okay I'm queuing again
I even put a press start like it's a
game
how long do you plan on doing fight
clubs forever actually I'm having a lot
of fun
I don't know what's the password you got
to be a member to get the password
hi
oh I like that armor you look kind of
cool [ __ ]
I'm coming for you
Bang Bang
whips scare me bro
but I'd use them you know what I mean
I think the reload fakes people out
foreign
you don't think I come right at you
after you hit me
oh okay it did hit I was like what
great fight
close one whip scare the [ __ ] out of me
the screen is cool okay I'm glad you
like it
okay sounds good Finn
foreign
good fight good fight good fight
see you in again human up keeping up
keeping up
if destined death is sealed away what is
the point of eating
because you can still be hungry
you know
does that make sense
I don't think so angel
we gotta get more members I'm trying to
find more ways for people to join the
channel like become members it's YouTube
doesn't really have a membership
culture yet I'm trying to change that
trying to change that
all right let's go again a little
rematch
favorite boss besides radon malakith
I think he's cool
radagon is a great fight as well
[Music]
[Music]
last to do sax metal or Fortis X
she's gonna say yes
you mean the dragon in Lim grave
great fight
yet again
I the crossbow really makes this build
so interesting to me because I have that
option and it does a decent amount of
damage
just know if I weren't broke I'd
remember up get it remember up nice
that's a good one
foreign
GG
we go again
a stogie
also metal how is your doggy did you say
that he's crazy dude yeah puppies are
[ __ ] nuts by the way dude it's a good
luck with that Joy was [ __ ] insane
when I first got her
[Music]
I'll become a member soon just to buy a
gift card because gpay won't accept my
credit you have to buy a gift card to
become a member oh God I'm sorry
somebody gift this guy a membership
I think gifted memberships are a thing
dogs are a good time
did I get a picture of the doggy
yes oh he's dead he's so cute
ah shield and spear hi
somebody give this guy a membership he's
been struggling all night
it drips in here
oh
I very rarely fought a spear
foreign
[Music]
up close it doesn't really work as good
oh my God
what
huh
what
can I get can I get that one explain to
me guys
I'm confused
and hurt a little
it's not as bad now good fight
I I thought I killed you earlier but
good fight
gifted memberships are a thing but I
don't think you could choose which one
it goes to that's so dumb
that's so stupid
why can't they just do that you know
like just do everything that twitch has
gift roulette gotta sub until yup guys
just keep gifting memberships until
drizz drips gets one okay
did the broke Poise just not register I
don't know that was really weird
that made no sense uh but it's okay
it's okay
I mean we go again it's kind of just me
and Angel though unfortunately
join up guys membership is only three
bucks if you want to join
I'm sure if we just do this more more
people will join in
we gotta create that culture you know
which takes time
I'm still having a really good time
oh my God your puppy is so cute he's so
cute
hey
hello again
no I hate this
you know I don't like these weapons that
you're using
[Music]
an animation let's go
[Music]
all right you're a speedy demon
I went for it
oh you have so many pokes
you found the build
the lag
the lag walk was so weird there
actually almost one right there
dude I knew if I just swung right there
I think I would have killed you
I'm being kind of a [ __ ] right now
sorry
let's go I'm ready
poke
no you have so many Pokey boys good
fight gg gg
uh apparently this is a thing can you
believe it's only been six months feels
like four years huh new friends
it just didn't work it didn't come up
yet I'm sorry metal
um I appreciate the six months even
though you've been subbed on Twitch for
like four years
so thank you metal I appreciate it
Parts in the chat no worries is all part
of the competitive nature it really is
it really do be
okay
we go again I guess I'm just fighting
Angel all day baby
all night
we go again
I hit you with the one two
the boom boom
I'm having a lot of fun with this build
though
cool
the crossbow
makes it super fun and then like P the
PVP seems to be a lot about timing
movement spacing
different types of attacks heavy light
Oak attacks having that little bit of
range
having the dagger as well
I'm here for you
you have so many pokes
I'm crowd Chardonnay
I didn't even know I was crouched
when I throw a dagger I can't even see
it
I thought I had you in a backstab No Cap
nice good trade interesting trade
take that poke double hit nope
I very rarely go for the second one
[Music]
no my dagger hit come on
[ __ ]
you're lagging like crazy bro
all right gotcha got you slipping GG
it's tough
that was a close one actually you had me
there
taking a shot each time your opponent
lags you're oh man
you're done
you're done so bro
okay metal
okay
I'm telling you man the bolts are nuts
aren't they
the bolts make this heavy build just so
versatile
everyone spams bolts and gold waves I
wouldn't say I'm spamming I'm doing like
a good mix of the two
it makes sense for a heavy sword build
to have something with range right
nah man
oh I know you're not joking I did not
think you were joking at all
what the [ __ ] what's that run
your character like didn't move its arms
run from me
Bonk
gonna
oh
you were changing [ __ ] up
I see
that was a really good timing there
foreign
baby
GG
you think there's lore behind the
coliseums
I think I could explore
I don't think I can can I
there's a statue of America and every
one of them
which I found interesting to see a
statue of America in caled
gg gg
gotta go hopefully see us again have fun
see you Joe have a good one sir
I think rodley might be
45 minutes behind
I think Italian says it was used during
Godfrey's reign as Eldon Lord the
Talisman or the Colosseum
the one outside of uh
laying down or inside whatever you know
what I mean the one in Landell
oh we've switched to the aggressive
curved blades
I wanted to trade
oh I went for that close it there okay
foreign
[Music]
come
forth
yeah
GG that timing was nuts once I saw the
your uh I forget what you're using once
I saw it come out I'm like oh you're
using a spell and I just threw a dagger
feet are kind of gross I mean [ __ ] gg gg
that was a good one
that was a good one
[Music]
I wish there was a way to just re-cue
yes scepter
Jake vouch
uh I don't know what you're talking
about
when radagon became Elden Lord they fell
out of use because Godfrey's rain Only
the Strong could lead
hi
hey
lead
is this how they determine who could
lead
I don't know what you're talking about
Metal
oh
it's over
I can't possibly win
unless
it's over
yep
dang it
gg gg
that's the bow from the chick
uh
before you battle with Dawn
maybe lead was a strong word right
it seems like the golden order
was really into
I mean if you watched my last video with
Godfrey
they were really into constant combat
you know what I mean
constant combat
snow more members active I guess not
members are done
it's just me and you
hey
okay
okay
this [ __ ] blades bro
steady
steady
steady
[ __ ]
uh it's because we come out of the
animation running I think that's what
happens okay wait wait wait hold on hold
on hold on hold on so I'm gonna wave
and then I'm gonna run
and then my arms are just gonna dangle
yeah look at that
you can't roll you can't roll you gotta
you gotta just run to one side
so I'm just gonna run to the right
stiff arm
isn't that weird
you [ __ ]
all right
that was a good move and you know it
okay give it a try run on one side
you didn't run
hey
is holding
the stiff Farm thing is so weird
nice
the timing
no I wanted the trade
[ __ ] I'm dead
foreign
good shot
good stuff good stuff
I've been working on the coliseums the
whole time
huh
like trying to get to him
you had to like re-download the game
right
a good fight good fight
those BL I'm struggling against that
weapon man
I'm struggling
[Music]
[Laughter]
I think we might do one more Angel and
then I might just go do random fights
until like more members want to fight
you know
I think that's what makes the PVP a lot
of fun is like getting different
variants of people to fight against you
know
and hopefully so on some other nights
we'll just have more people you know
yeah I really wish it was cross-platform
I'm actually super surprised it's not
wrong emote
I'm coming for you get snapping me
can't snap oh
okay you can snap I'm sorry [ __ ] man
I can't believe that hit me
the bolt
I got a limited amount of time to kill
you
don't wave at me
whoa
got you right at you
dang dude I am super dead
yep I'm super dead
GG look at all the bolts in your body
though
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
dude fight good fight good stuff you're
killing me at the end there man all
right we're gonna keep we're gonna cue
into randoms until more people uh join
up bro
it's a good fight
yeah I want to find a way to like be
able to keep track of fights that'd be
fun
let me get rid of this
hello video game
there we go
and we're gonna do
I just like doing duels I might be weird
about that but I just kind of like it
they're fun
I'm hitting a blinker what is your car
like a car blinker what are you talking
about
twin Lance's op and PVP
I feel
tell me if I'm wrong here but if I I
feel like if you're actually good at the
PVP
you can make any weapon work and be and
win a fight
you know like even if you go up against
like The Meta quote unquote
does that make sense
hope this convinces people to join maybe
like make a
rep I don't know that word
repulatory
heading to blinkerton City who's that
what is that
or she's heading to blinkerton City
a blinker is when you hit the stizzy so
long the light will start to Blink and
it automatically stops
what
I forgot you started smoking so good for
you
probably a good idea I'm not gonna lie
can't find any matches
a video with the best fights today
do you think like AGT Jakey
can be used for that
I don't know
because
I I don't think I need to to stream on
another Channel I don't think I need to
do that
we were talking about that a little bit
earlier I don't think that's
because it there's a totally separate
tab on YouTube now that just makes it so
much
uh I'm just gonna cancel this it makes
it so much
uh better now to where my live streams
don't get mixed in with my videos you
have to literally go to the live tab to
even be able to see it you know what I
mean
so I I think it's totally fine I don't
think it messes with the channel I don't
think it does
but I definitely can't post PVP
highlights on the main channel on this
channel that would be bad
we are only doing lore and live streams
on this channel
I can't find a match
I was also wanting to do a playthrough
of the game again as Bill Clinton
if they release the mod to look like
Bill Clinton oh my God that would be
funny
[Music]
Pineapple Express
I feel like that's like a brand you say
when you don't know what it is
yeah I removed the password
yep sure did
oh I didn't
I did
well that that helps a lot
I did though
and it just got put back on
that's frustrating oh well thank you for
telling me that I swear I did but okay
and we get in a fight immediately like
what the what the [ __ ] bro
all right who we got here
please hey
hey hi yo bro give it a sec man
you're aggressive
people in PvP just want to get in it huh
you seemed a little far away I ain't
gonna cap
I I couldn't even see him use that
attack this guy's lagging
this guy seems good
[Music]
nice
we're coming back
[Music]
I would have killed you
let's go we came back baby that was a
great fight
I feel myself getting better I feel it
bro
let's go
that was a great fight
bam
I'm back I had this special Pride theme
pen with limited edition strain bow and
it was [ __ ] fire
that does sound [ __ ] fire
hell yeah
no that's literally what it is I also
have blue dream King Lotus and green
crack all right good to know
okay you guys yeah Green Crack is nice
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah really
re-fight keep it up dot dot dot was that
not a good fight I thought it was that
was [ __ ] sick
I
aha
smoking that true G
this guy's like a strong wizard
no
thank you
that was uh not what I wanted to do
yeah this guy's a wizard
mm-hmm
[Music]
he waited for me to dodge
foreign
I think I'm gonna have to hit him with a
heavy voice
on purpose
right
I'm getting better I saw you see that
[ __ ] I'm learning
I'm learning
foreign
tactics
[Music]
no
no hey dude
he has almost nothing
his health is so low
my beloved nice
I want to do that that's [ __ ] sick
hold on
he just throws that on
it's one of the items you can just put
in your inventory right
I got everything
apologies I'm gonna do that
that was such a good fight though that
was awesome
my friend had some flour called Mandarin
cookies and it literally smelled like
chocolate
my friend in college we made a bunch of
pot brownies pretty much
and he thought they were regular
brownies and ate like four
he uh
he had a bad night
hi
Mage cook
good good this is a good name no highs
though huh
okay I can I can feel it
I can understand
okay that's a that's an attack I haven't
seen before
no he's [ __ ] redone oh God
wait why can't I shoot what what what
wait I have no bolts left why don't I
have any bolts I thought they respawned
every time
what
I guess not
damn that's gonna [ __ ] my build
let's go baby
that's kind of lit saying my apologies
after you kill someone
maybe you just ran out of them in the
inventory
right I need to craft more
oh they're like actually not there
should I use a different one like can I
use a poison Bolt
I have like 99 of everything let's try
it that was a great fight too that was a
GG as well
I smoked some [ __ ] called lavender once
and it tasted like lavender and smelled
like it too but was powerful
you guys believe I've just never done
drugs my entire life I've never even
tried them
just didn't want to I played video games
instead
hi
okay poison bolts no high again double
spear didn't someone say that earlier
yep oh yeah wow okay
all right yeah the double spear
seems pretty good
like God damn
that ended my whole day
wow
video games are my drugs that's what I'm
saying bro
you're like a weak Warlock
I bet it smelled like weed people always
tell me they smell different
I just only smell skunk yep that's what
it smells like it smells like skunk
I
MJ okay
you're more courteous
to see you bro
that is a very quick snap
good timing
even better timing
I don't think that poisoned him though
unfortunately
foreign
[Laughter]
that was a good fight
good stuff
he tried to Parry me bro
where's the Perry God should I trade in
the bolt for a Parry guys
like a like a
I don't know
like a buckler oh I should have the
option yeah
just have both
still
yeah we're good
smoking weed could change how you play
fighting games
yeah that's okay I'm good without I'm I
think it's a good thing that I'm I don't
have to be high
uh to feel fine
I wasted three hours of my time only to
find out there's an issue with my credit
card drips I'm so sorry
use big cannon I tried to and I don't
know how to use it it seems weird oh God
hey
hey look at this this guy's Poise must
be through the [ __ ] roof bro
should I try the Perry
I feel like trying to Parry this guy is
gonna be a big No-No
that was an interesting attack
double hammered up
on a Tuesday
it's Sunday though
man I'm hitting through him huh
I went for it chat I did I shouldn't
have
I went for the Perry on a jump attack
I should have been one shot
I thought I could hit him before you
could hit me good fight
I shouldn't have gone for the Perry I
think that's why I lost
I like his look
that's my dad beat him for me your dad's
too powerful
I just shouldn't have gone for the Perry
that was stupid I don't even think you
could Parry that
can you parry a jump heavy attack
I don't think you can Parry a jump
attack actually I could be wrong huh
or I missed
only in Sakura
I miss sakiro
sky looks cool
a golden champion
what does that mean
okay that was totally visible to me huh
guys
I went for it [ __ ] I should have backed
off and hit him with the bow dude dang
it
good fight
dang it bro
that guy's cool
ah
I don't think pairing is [ __ ]
possible in PV to be I also got hit by
some dumbass
like
lag hit bro feels bad
feels bad man
you can actually draw yeah you can if
time expires there's a draw
pretty rare though
yo
let's go
I don't want to be the first one to
attack
no a moon valer huh
rare nowadays
let me up Daddy
you like that pause there chat
that's good
[Music]
no I was changing my weapon
dang it
I have too many things
[ __ ]
feels bad
you can only knock someone out of the
air dang dude okay
oh I would have won that fight too I got
in such a good hit
yeah I just haven't seen a moon veil in
a while
I don't think that was the moon
available why I lost there I was just
scrolling to my thing
these builds are really cool to look at
though
his name is rest in peace
okay if you're gonna do that I can do
this
why is he facing the other way
what
how did I not hit him right there what
what
foreign
[Music]
bro
he's kind of laggy
that was weird
that fight didn't feel right
what is say that here you're this I
think that's been mentioned twice I
don't know what that is
that that seemed like a weird fight
like I
a couple of times I don't think I should
have been hit but I was
there must be a lot of people queuing
all right who we got
some PC
hey
I said it at the same time
I love it when people run straight at me
bro
foreign
[Music]
that is such a cool
weapon art
foreign
interesting trade
what
that first one should not have hit me
ugh
man dude lag is really coming into play
on these last like three fights
damn bro
uh if you
what
it's where you can make yourself
practically invulnerable to damage
while dealing a lot of damage
what does that have to do with Save
Editor I don't know what that means
they roll catch you a lot
only when they have like a poker like
that or a spear
if I roll backwards I always get hit by
the spear
hi
good
we go
we fight
just powered right through that huh
man tries a Parry
I am behind him all right I I feel like
I'm getting [ __ ] on by lag right now
over and over again
yeah you can use physic flask I just
never do
it's not like that big of a difference
doesn't seem like anyway
I'm like behind the guy there I guess
the end of his swing could have hit me
Stave editors can make you have higher
health and damage amount on your weapons
how I don't know what that is what is
this I don't know what a save editor
does that sounds like a a hack
heavy weapons guy nice
boom boom boom Oh my goodness
dude I am getting [ __ ] on by everyone
right now bro
foreign
there and my hip just didn't
I don't know
dude like what is that like some of
these matches just don't feel right you
know
like that's such a delayed hit too [ __ ]
man it's it's pretty frustrating when
it's like super prevalent in a match
yeah
you're tweaking the file numbers
so you can do that
I thought it would like ban you if you
did that
it is a hack you can edit your saved
game data to lock your health at Max
reduce your roll time animation increase
your stats basically anything
it's the cheat engine okay I know what
that is
interesting
hmm
and that doesn't like
okay interesting
I don't feel like I've faced anybody who
has like an obnoxious amount of Health
oh okay
it's popular in Pokemon games to make
high stat monsters
pain
colossals have the hardest are the
hardest for me in PvP they're very slow
yeah it's the game is pretty much all
about timing you know
hey all right big peepee
a very Godly name
the range on that
you gotta be out of FP
foreign
well that wasn't worth it I'll tell you
that right now
literally facing a Gideon
keeps running away
oh my god dude I am getting annihilated
by [ __ ] everybody right now
everybody is beating me right now bro
damn
I thought I was good too no I'm not I'm
getting put down in my place
Dark Souls one PVP
be cool if you're attacked with the
Enemy hits you gets us
struggle match
oh no I don't want a qte or anything
like that
um
okay
I'm not even gonna try to pronounce that
one
we got a samurai here
wow those are some long-ass katanas man
and I'm just instantly dead okay
your damage is absolutely insane my guy
I won't lie
those katanas absolutely [ __ ]
annihilated me
wow
I can't beat anybody this is sad
I'm getting sad
I don't think they weren't gold so
they're not melania's blades
they were like silver
dirty casual
oh that's a whip
that one doesn't really hurt that much
but it's very surprising
like it comes out fast
nice finally
I can't really hear the apologies one
that good
anything goes Mr B
we did it we want to match it's a
[ __ ] miracle guys
okay let's change this apologies I can't
hear Hello thank you wonderful please
help you're beautiful let's get it let's
get to it my beloved
thank you
yes
yeah you you face people against your
who are at your own level right
or around it
[Music]
Guardian Lin
lingardian Leviosa
okay all right you know you could take
the time to say hi I I would appreciate
it but
okay you're you're in it I feel you
some good movement this person is
extremely aggressive
I need to stop back rolling
[Music]
yep I just knew I could win I knew I
could win the battle
[ __ ]
in a bow
two in a row guys let's go
yeah it's around it
uh not all time at level 300 I was
fighting peeps at 130 due to them having
max level weapons
I mean
wouldn't it just like kind of Nerf you a
bit like in terms of health
PVP is not for me you know I thought the
same thing man I would personally give
it a try I'm having more fun than I
thought I would you know
but that hit by the way
like my health went down but I didn't
see it actually hit me
oh you're kind of annoying
you're you're kind of really annoying
[Music]
that little pedal
hit
is insane
why did I roll so fast
my bad
that little Pebble attack was [ __ ]
annoying it also hit me or it didn't hit
me but my health went down
weird
would be cool if they added a tournament
mode with Spectators there's a lot they
need to add to this you know what they
need to do is give people a reason to do
it
like give give them a rune Arc for
winning or something you know
something like that they
they there's the rank thing
doesn't seem like it means anything
does it
the little icon next to your name
doesn't seem like it means anything
hi why do they have the fast High I want
to have the fast High
okay okay yep yep
you have that
the Dingle bingas
the Dingle dingus
I just went for it man oh
got him
[ __ ] dude I thought I could roll and
reload dang it
good fight that was actually really good
[ __ ] dude
that's how it starts you love PVP then
you get annoyed by the flaws then he
quit there are a lot of them bro
there are
it's I would say it's mainly the lag
I wish the hits felt like it did in the
normal game because they don't it feels
like I just swing and I'm not hitting
anything until I see their their health
bar go down
in the in the main game you feel like
you're actually hitting your opponent
you know or the boss
does that make sense
oh [ __ ] you
this guy just went at it
Moon Veil and all
so this guy is every what everyone was
talking about huh
oh my God
foreign matchmaking
what a dick
he just went at me right from the start
pain
why would that be less laggy I think
that would be more laggy if I turn that
off
because I'm getting people outside my
region
oh Nani
I'm having fun with my crossbow
and probably try a different build
another day
all right I'll go [ __ ] myself
wow
that fire lasted a very long time I
thought I just went behind it but it
Lingus
don't listen to the haters
I don't think anybody's hating are they
[ __ ] you if you're hating hater [ __ ]
ass hater
what's up Mikey uh it's the other way
around if you have matchmaking on you
fight people from other regions
oh cross region matchmaking okay gotcha
a Battle Royale in Elden ring let's not
I think battle rails are actually dying
okay we got a good boy
why do some people look behind
I've noticed this from two people
wait why did I lose any health what
happened
when did I get hit what
what the [ __ ]
oh you have to be facing forward that's
kind of dumb
let's go
foreign
no I like my build I'm having fun
I'm trying to learn my build it's fun
I'm just losing because I'm not doing it
right
I think if you're actually good at PVP
you can make any build work in win
against anybody
but I have to learn my build
how many belly Rubes does Joy get hey
she's gonna get a hundred thousand tummy
rubs if we get to a hundred thousand
[ __ ] subscribers
we're really really close but we we grow
very steadily very slowly on in the
daily
it's a poison bow look he's facing the
other way how do so many people know to
do this
holy [ __ ]
we've been at 96 000.
for three months and now we just got the
95.
oh my God
I hate this person
oh you play weird and I don't like it
my mean for saying that
or a [ __ ] oh my God
that's the second person in a row that
spam spells while looking the opposite
direction
I don't know why that bothered me so
much
long overdue for 100k I mean I kinda
stopped uploading as often which makes
sense that we didn't get to 100K
oh but I'm trying to upload more now
is there a YouTuber guide to getting
more subs yeah make good content and
then you get subs
but I should have another vid like
another lore video out in the next day
or two
probably two days
now you're seeing why people hate PVP I
don't hate it it's just some things are
kind of annoying
that would honestly just make me stop
playing for the day you know
oh that's cool
this guy looks cool
whoa whoa what is that
what the [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
no what is that I have never seen that
before
I thought it was over so I kept swinging
but that thing kept going
holy [ __ ] that was crazy
man all right man [ __ ]
let's see champion
you should do a mass collab with others
maybe a debate
nah
nah
I have my style my my lore videos are
good the last two I put out have been
[ __ ] bangers if I keep doing that
we'll get to 100 000 Subs
uh
okay this guy's name is Dark Souls 3 I
love it
that didn't hit him by the way
okay you have a massive amount of Health
what the [ __ ]
okay
there isn't anybody to collab with
I don't know
I think DLC will drop in February do you
see what band Kai Namco tweeted
that you should look out in the upcoming
days and weeks for updates on Eldon ring
which was surprising it could be a
somewhat of a
uh
mistranslation
but seems promising
Oh I thought he just Zapped me no high
we not highing no Highs at all
come on Squidward you gotta relax buddy
all right that [ __ ] goes a while
gotta stop back rolling bro
yes I back for old more
how many [ __ ] incantations you have
let's go
that guy had a lot going on there
but we hit him with our big big thing
next year's gonna be a great year for
games there were a lot of great
announcements for games I'm very excited
yeah that was a good win that one felt
good
so far it's the longest wait for DLC
of any of the other games yes
definitely Dark Souls 3 they had they
released in March and they had DLC by
October
in Elden Ring released and oh we got
Squidward again we uh released in
February and now it's December with
nothing besides an update so
foreign
that's so cringe dude
that has gotta be the most unskilled
[ __ ] incantation in PVD
okay
what's your favorite weapon
honestly the ruins great sword
you're gonna be torn and you'll play it
largest game to date
I mean did you guys see their
announcements at the game awards I I
watched it again
they made it pretty clear that they've
had some struggles with Eldon ring in
terms of development of it
that it's been hard they can't just dish
out DLC you know because it's a
successful game you know
they don't release [ __ ] they release
good finish content
yeah I mean
okay
good good
you're a poison build
foreign
no he did so much damage holy [ __ ]
hi Shazam
this guy is such a poison build holy
[ __ ]
every Shard Bearer has potential oh with
DLC yeah they could go so many different
routes they could do anything they want
hmm
yeah it's not easy to make video games
guys as much as we want DLC they
probably come across
you know
a lot of problems
so they're this guy's name is Mother
what a fit we got going on here huh
I this person is all up in my [ __ ]
foreign
how am I not hitting you there we go
how do you have this much health with no
armor what
is this the thing you guys are talking
about there's no way I just did that
little damage
to someone with basically wearing a
[ __ ] nothing basically
oh
I'm dead didn't mean to do that
shut up I must have no Health what is my
health at
three out of 2007. holy [ __ ]
the re-health
close one
that person had a [ __ ] ton of Health
wow
uh tan man Dark Souls 3 had I mean I
just said this they released the game in
March of 2016 and they had DLC by
October
bought you didn't we fight earlier
I remember this build
Greg I don't remember Greg I'd remember
Greg
thank you
oh with a little back step huh
I tried to jump it
I find that hard to believe that one
didn't hit
oh my God
foreign
that's my first backstab
so they must be getting poisoned
some reason I tried to jump
and that was kind of dumb
we [ __ ] Drew
these combat who who wins
stalemate that's actually [ __ ] cool
wow
nice
I thought it was gonna be like defeat
like really
come on
foreign
go back in time have a major role in the
shattering Roar yep
that's what I think it's going to be too
there's been so many
Winks at time travel
if you can make your own great your own
great Rune what would it do
uh
the ability to get [ __ ] whenever I
want
I was in blood
oh
this guy looks cringe
weren't people complaining about that
attack
did he jump it
okay I don't know why
that freaked me out but it did
bloodborne DLC came out in November
eight months after bloodborne's initial
release
oh well it doesn't matter
I don't think we're gonna get DLC
um I'd be surprised if we got a DLC
announcement before March at this point
I think sometime in March we'll get an
announcement for the summer
Maybe
Kanata are you going to wave
hi
no
okay
yeah you're one of those people
weird you can like feel someone's
personality
with this
like how he was moving around and how he
has a moon Veil katana
you know
that makes sense
how did that not hit you
oh my spam God damn
that was annoying I did not like that at
all
no wave spamming Moonville whatever
that was probably my least favorite
fight of the night
that was not
fun
yeah it's over a year tan man
they have to competing with a lot of
Heavy Hitters
what no they don't
I appreciate that Patty I'm glad you
like them dude
hi
let's go
really
foreign
oh
let's fight
[Music]
I just didn't go for the hit and he did
damn
I wanted to fake a jump
and I thought he'd do the same
damn
until I get him to roll or something
well Ronaldo's hat like increases
something with intelligence doesn't it
so that's why you'll see people with
moonvale
wear that hat
oh
hey it's a big double hammer boy again
I [ __ ] did it
two of them boys
let's go
wow
was not expecting that to say the least
oh
if it's paid DLC they are a business and
have to consider that their fans are
also fans of bigger franchises
I disagree with that completely
they will make so much money again
putting out any kind of DLC
I think most people will drop whatever
game they're playing to play whatever
Elven ring releases again
I guarantee it
um
I'm getting kind of [ __ ] aren't I chat
like everybody is destroying me
I gotta work around with that more I
think
what
foreign
he's not even facing me and I didn't
even see an attack that hit me
he like didn't I didn't even see him
thrust and I got hit by nothing
you're lacking movement probably I don't
[ __ ] know
this is like my literal first day of PVP
in any Souls game
I feel like I'm doing pretty good
for the most part
this guy scares me
what
I don't even think I should have hit you
buddy
this is just annoying like I can't
what
do you that is the most frustrating
thing about the PVP is when they're just
stuttering around and you like can't do
anything
foreign
but they don't seem to be lagging at all
I guess
Elden Ring's content won't be all games
I don't know what that means
no I just like dueling
I've tried Ruby threes it's just kind of
Chaos
oh buddy
what is this [ __ ]
forgot the load
Vari bleed build
much
I'm just trying to like
strafe them
not working super well
what
so that's just a roar huh
waking is not as bad an Elden ring
that last fight was pretty [ __ ] bad
it's like he was disappearing every
second
Souls games have always had that problem
can I ask has PVP
does it have a large community
I don't even know
I would say the game is mostly PV ears
more than likely
foreign
okay
uh I should shoot you
I'm going to keep shooting
all right
I'm officially getting annoyed
holy [ __ ] dude
I can't believe that one shot me wow
I thought I rolled and I just didn't
most have gone yes it's a huge community
yes and no kind of
okay that's a lot of answers a lot of
different answers
look up creators like prod chase the bro
or a borrow
gotcha
do you like the PVP I can't tell like I
was having fun earlier and now I'm not
because of like I'm noticing all the
subtle kind of annoyances of
the PVP
yeah I think landel's the best Coliseum
foreign
I think I'm just getting annoyed at this
point
[Music]
because I'm like I'm not trying to roll
too much and now I'm thinking about how
much I'm rolling
and yeah
are you trying to stream snipe me Steven
most people play the PVP for a bit
before realizing it's kind of ass
because of how broken the builds are and
how bad the connection is I have a
uh honestly I don't care about the
builds the builds or whatever
you can you can have any kind of build
and I think that's fine I think that's
creative
the only thing that annoys me is the lag
I would say like that truly annoys me
and that I think is like kind of
unacceptable is how bad the lag is in
pretty much every fight
foreign
well I do want to fight you that is
against like TOS by the way she probably
shouldn't tell me you're trying to
stream study me
Jesus Christ
can I even beat you
what is this oh
what
you are an interesting person
foreign
so many different things to think about
I just saw him do it once I guess you
can choose to go one tail swipe or two
tails wipes
the Glenstone spells have weird latency
I've noticed that they like hit you when
you don't even notice that they hit you
you just like have to look at your
health bar
and you'll notice that it's down
I have fought a different person pretty
much every time I've fought drips I have
not had that experience
you finally ready drips or not drips
pump
hey
hey
I
stop using that big ass sword it's my
build what do you mean stop using the
sword
I like using it
[Music]
[ __ ]
ES
man I've seen that attack a few times
tonight too
it's pretty weird it's hard to see
[ __ ]
[Music]
what
fair enough
unexpected
oh come on
man that [ __ ] comes out fast
wow
this is really annoying
okay
they just went full on Range that's so
dumb bro
okay whatever
that was just super annoying
God damn I like couldn't do anything
I was born ready okay are you in the
Discord
the
Fight Club Discord
a [ __ ] Robin Hood bro
Trump hello
guys I I know you're trying to help me
but I'm I'm not gonna take your advice
I'm sorry
you got the password in okay cool
it's trial and error for me to get
better obviously
yeah maybe the actual War can change
I I like my build
I I don't think there's anything wrong
with it and I like fighting with it
uh just you know I'm not good enough at
PVP or don't have enough experience
if I go up against someone who's good at
PVP I will lose
probably
it's to each their own
not allowed to have Discord
what are you [ __ ] 12
it is a gut spilled
close
that's not good how the [ __ ] did you
find this channel then
yeah Again by the way this is literally
like my first real day doing any PVP at
all
I'm I'm not gonna
get it right away
I'm gonna have good fights and I'm gonna
have really bad fights
I like Elden ring all right that's crazy
man
you can play Elden ring but you're not
allowed to have Discord
it's interesting
I'm waiting on you Pat or uh
Trump did you put in the right password
make sure it's dual
any location
the most recent one at 6 52.
hopefully you're trying to do it from
the Round Table
foreign
a sweet and sour Burger
that was one interesting what
I'm confused
Eldon Discord can allow offensive
wording Elden ring cannot
offensive wording
I mean I guess
you're matching with other people did
you put in the password because if
you're putting in the password
that can't be possible
if you're matching with other people
buddy
are you just guessing Mr B
okay
I'm trying again man
that's kind of what I'm asking random
well I I say it's interesting because
um
my
uh
I mean let me look at my Analytics
what is my age range for my channel
if you guys had to guess what do you
think my age range is okay there we go
finally
holy [ __ ]
let me take a look
Giga check
I'll tell you after this
what a build you're a big boy
there's all my moves
I'm pretty much dead if he hits me once
huh
cool
this is a cool build man
[Music]
that was risky
we went for it though
I think we both just missed each other
there
one to 99 great guess
whoops I meant to bow
BG
uh okay so
2.4 of my audience is 13 to 17 years old
2.4 percent
36.2 percent are between the ages of 18
and 24.
and my largest percentage
is 41.7 percent
with 25 to 34 years old
and then 13.9 percent is 35 to 44
percent
so basically
55 of my audience is between the ages of
25 and 44.
but if this if this guy's saying he's
close to 12 years old
he's in the 2.4 percent
you're a minute behind Trump God damn
bro all right I'm queuing again if you
want to fight again
I probably need to get off pretty soon
guys
I'm having fun
but uh man the PVP is frustrating isn't
it
I mean I didn't doubt you were close to
12.
wasn't doubting you brother
yeah
all right brother
barbaric Roar interestante
PVP walking me
stay on forever
I don't think I can do that
that was a good timing for that
foreign
oh thank God I reached you
GG
I don't think anything's wrong with
Stefan is it Stefan or Steven
Steve did I mention I'm trash I have no
idea what's good or bad man I am this is
my first day like I said
it's frustrating because you won't use a
different weapon I'm just letting you
know
that has nothing to do with me being
frustrated at all
I am having fun with this build
oh I just showed it didn't I [ __ ]
oh well
even
Eve
hop on the all Pally build
okie dokie probably have to change the
password now but who knows
yeah I'll change the password
I might I might get off I'm actually
[ __ ] tired
yeah I'm tired boys
I think I'm gonna get off
but yeah just you the weapon has nothing
to do with why I'm frustrated
I'm not even frustrated I think I'm just
tired but the I can see why people stop
playing the PVP is all I'm saying
no Jake you're not tired it's okay
[Laughter]
you're Wide Awake
one last free-for-all all right I'll
change the password though hold on
let's make it
this
oh not that
old
there you go and it'll be
uh
combat ordeal for combatants do we have
four
will you do this again please no you
don't want me to do this again
what oh
oh it can't be that long uh take out the
I'll change it I'll update it boom there
you go
the it was too long
why does it randomly change
so weird okay
do we need one more
if you insist on that build then you
gotta work on your movement patty melt
why do you keep saying [ __ ] like this I
don't care it's fine
I'm gonna be frustrated if my movement's
good or not
War Thunder players are nationalistic
Cod players how are you close to the age
of 12 and saying things like this
laughs
holy [ __ ] drips did it
you did it boys
it finally worked
well now you gotta come for the last
free-for-all bro
thank you drips
thank you man
appreciate it appreciate it a lot
did Jake not see how did people not see
how Jake played thymesia that's a great
example rodly
if you guys didn't see how I played
thymesia I did not upgrade my character
I did not
get a better weapons
I didn't do that any of that I banged my
head against a wall until I figured it
out that is how I work
and there's nothing wrong with that
that's how I decide to play
so like yeah I could use a weapon that's
a little better I don't want to
oh I haven't even started queuing yet
Angel should I okay I'm gonna start the
queue now
huge problem why
[ __ ]
oh we got it we got everybody let's go
we're in
and that's why we love them that's
that's how I do everything man
what the heck
my game's lagging oh my controller be
synced
okay we're good
I I just do it over and over again until
I figure it out
nah
now
oh I thought you were our fourth yeah
well then we need one more after you
drips
because we you have to have six I think
ah that hurts
I think I'm not gonna be alive in a
second
yep I was right start keeping on no
you're fine we're gonna do this anyway
it's fine we'll do this again
for sure
I don't think I'm gonna do it every day
because I gotta work on lore videos
but we'll definitely do this a lot it's
fun it's fun when we're doing this when
I'm just cueing against like dueling
against random people
not as fun
for sure
oh I got you too
leave me alone
[ __ ]
feel myself lagging
oh
damn I wish my Stomp staggered
I don't think I would have got it off in
here
uh not really Steven
I'm working
I should have a video on the chapel of
anticipation
in like a day or two
stole mine kill
third
[Music]
hello
foreign
yep that hurt
hey don't haunt me [ __ ] you
that sounds very nice danesca
I'm in Missouri and it's cold
yes ma'am rolling
wow I kind of stole that huh
[Music]
oh [ __ ] he came out of nowhere
so the next game is ordeal with six I
don't think we have six I think we only
have five
and I don't think it works unless we
have the full number unfortunately
on my man upgraded okay I see you
I appreciate that drips
what no
no hit by the thing
there
let's go drips
wow
eaten
that didn't work
I love live streaming
[Music]
yeah
very nice
live streaming on YouTube is very weird
though
it's different from twitch
I definitely like it more than twitch
though
I streamed on Twitch for four years so
it's hard to get used to
wait wait
Bang
that didn't work
great job
GG
I'm so tired randomly now holy crap
we'll do one more for drips we'll let
him we'll let him join
looks like Angel's giving him a spot
appreciate that
foreign
I don't know what my favorite looking
enemy is that's a good question
haven't thought of that
um
hmm
I don't know
I don't know
I think the ancestral Spirits look
really cool
if you ever look close at them with
their like shredded off skin
should drips be blue you mean green
huh
waiting on two people still by the way
members only Paul
the bow guys
no I mean the
the [ __ ] uh
you know the Regal ancestral spirit
the the Moose deer whatever
or deal with four in any location with
the password
I thought Blue Thumb was a great Blue
Thumb what is Blue Thumb
you mean the logo
Crown bum does it look like a thumb
no uh no so that is based on how many
months you've been a subscriber or a
member
it changes based off that
so if you've been a member for like more
than three months it'll change to Blue
if it's your first sub it's the same
logo
there we go all combatants have
assembled
holy [ __ ]
that's a man over there
oh you see that Dodge though bro
and I missed
lava cool
are there only three
huh how did this happen
how is this possible
well that hurt
oh I got him jumping bro
and the range on that's crazy Victor
I think you're dead though yep oh
what the that's Madness
craziness
uh okay I'm just gonna stand in these
no
oh it canceled for you
can you join in after the fact I haven't
thought I haven't seen that before
I think Bang Bang
get poisoned
foreign
that attack's pretty cool
uh
nice
holy [ __ ] those blades are nuts
oh my God
it's waiting for three others gotcha
that's freaking weird
looks like it would have a like AOE
effect but it just doesn't
[ __ ] spinny boys
[ __ ]
leave me alone
leave me alone
you're ganging up on me
come
[Music]
tournament huh that would be kind of
cool
I just don't know with how this PVP
works I don't know how we would properly
do that
I wish it was like what I've seen from
Dark Souls 3. where I could like host
and then you could like watch
it doesn't seem like that's possible in
this for some reason
which kind of sucks
stop it
I forgot I can heal
so used to the duels
sir
not fair
oh my God this is
circular boys
man you went right through that
yeah we'd have to do that if it were
updated in the future with how it is
right now we couldn't do anything close
to that
which is unfortunate
owie
okay I got him
oh God
yeah I'm playing with chat right now
GG
I think I lost
let's do another one so Finn can play
we'll do one more this is definitely the
last one by the way
how annoying was your build the [ __ ]
thingy
the
I forget what it's called the Golden uh
I keep thinking wheel but it's like all
the discs
that shit's so hard to dodge because
they just spread in the most awkward way
but GG guys we go again we go again
hopefully Finn can get into this one
what's y'all's favorite lore video
posted by Jake golden rings thank you I
just couldn't think of the word
oh you were magma blade [ __ ]
nah I like that build that build seems
cool
the armor is uh
Knights Cavalry armor with a just a
black hood
the rest is nice cavalry
I think this cape looks [ __ ] awesome
okay let's do our awkward run
ready for this guys arm's gonna be
straight down
really my most recent one is your
favorite
that's nice
did everyone get in this time yeah it
looks like it okay cool
I will take you on Victor
too far away
you know I hate this attack
good trade good trade
oh you turned yourself that's kind of
cool
I see what you're doing you're turning
yourself midair to hit me
you must be a PVP
[Music]
the radon one huh that one's old old
you know I made the radon video in like
30 minutes
isn't that crazy
oh my God
I'll let you take this one
I won't steal it from you
I might though
eat
am I gonna have to end this for you
I shall
I like the music in the coliseums too
they're very good
the wings
foreign
that one's my favorite personally
I think the like father like son I think
is the one you're talking about
is my best video
personally
dude those rings are so good
I couldn't move
back stop switch
thank you
ow
e
someone introduce you to the channel
I think that's uh yeah it's definitely
my most viewed video right the radon one
man how does that [ __ ] hurt so much God
damn
I was pretty far away from it too
[Music]
oh I died wow
Victor's damage is kind of crazy
bone boldened by the flame of ambition
I didn't have stamina I still don't
Victor you [ __ ] come here
yeah
oh wait
pain
I totally would have hit you there bro
GG
oh GG's guys
I am super tired that turned into a four
hour stream I thought I'd do this for
like an hour and a half two hours max
and we did it for four
ggs everybody thank you for playing
that's really fun
I like it I like the PVP I don't know if
I like uh public PVP
but I like fighting against you guys so
that's pretty fun
when you plan to stream again I don't I
don't know dude
I used to have a schedule with streaming
on here but we kind of did everything
you know
uh we played every soulsborne game we
beat Elden ring a hundred percent we did
the randomizer stream you know
we did the randomizer run
um
I don't really know what else to do on
stream PVP is fun I don't see it
something that we do every single day
but it's still very fun
it it seemed like in a way like I wish
it had more to it like one I wish it was
cross-platform like rocket League was
cross-platform so it was really easy to
make tournaments that way they also had
a tournament system inside of Rocket
league as well which
you know I would like to do stuff like
that for this game but they kind of have
it set up in a way where you kind of
can't so that kind of sucks
yeah we'll do this every now and then
um as for like normal streams I don't
really know what to do
like we we did everything
especially playing all the other games
we we beat every other game as well
on stream so
that's kind of it
you know what I mean
like I would say the like whenever DLC
comes out we're gonna play that
for the first time on stream 100 I would
never display that off stream I would
definitely do that live
um stuff like that
I think once a week for PVP sounds fun
do you guys want to do this on Sundays
oh Finn you're right we hit we didn't
beat Dark Souls 2
did I just grind through Dark Souls 2
and get to the end
that's the last thing we haven't done I
forgot about that
that could be fun just to have a regular
stream
but maybe we do fight club on Sundays
like Sunday nights that would be fun to
me
okay
I mean I'm gonna do what the members
want to do so let's do that let's for
now let's do PVP on Sundays maybe we can
increase it a couple times a week if we
really want to
yeah I like that
um I will think about Dark Souls 2 okay
I really well last time I tried maybe I
was in a bad mood that week or something
but I really didn't like it at all I
would I had such a bad time playing Dark
Souls 2 but then again I tried to stream
it on Twitch so maybe it'll be more fun
on YouTube again we'll see
I'll think about it all right I'll think
about it bro
anyway that's gonna be it for me today
thank you guys for playing thank you for
being here that was a lot of fun thanks
for all the memberships Super Chat stuff
like that you guys are always cool with
that stuff
um expect a new lore video out
in the next day or two I wouldn't say
definitely not tomorrow I would look
more toward Tuesday for the new lore
video on the chapel of anticipation
which actually turned out to be
um
really turned into a good video like it
uh I've written the entire script for it
and it's actually turned out to be
a good it turned out very good like
better than I thought it would so that's
exciting
I'll see you guys then
um but yeah well I'll think about Dark
Souls 2. if I'm really feeling like it
that is the next
the last thing that we kind of need to
do so all right everybody y'all have a
good one is there a criteria to getting
the fight club yes you have to be a
member that's it okay I'm out of here
boys have a good one and I will see you
soon peace out